what is going on everybody and welcome
to a tensor flow object detection API
overview slash tutorials so in this
video all we're going to be doing is
just doing it just a quick setup of the
tensor flow object detection API I'm
going to try to I'm going to be doing
this on Windows mostly since my main
focus of using the central other
detection API is in games which run on
Windows and not a boon to and not very
well as often on Mac so anyways I'm
going to be doing on Windows I will
point out a few slight differences not a
boon too but it's basically the setup is
the same so we're just going to set up
get to the point where we can detect
things in an image like this and then in
the subsequent videos we're going to
show how you might customize this to
your own images and then to your own
video and for my purposes the video will
just will use you know streaming video
from say Grand Theft Auto so anyway but
you could change that to be your webcam
or whatever and actually maybe first
I'll just do it with the webcam anyway
enough on that let's set this up so they
actually do have installation
instructions and you could totally just
follow those there's like a few things
that will hang you up though like for
example like installing the potential
flow GPU is not that simple it'd be
great if it was that simple it's not so
anyway so if you need instructions on
installing tensorflow GPU
I've got tutorials on that yeah so
anyway one thing to note that's actually
the reason why this is so useful is
detecting things and images has all has
been like something you could do for a
very long time but detecting objects in
images that you could stream those
images like on a video so like to detect
things at like 15 20 frames per second
especially if you want decent accuracy
is was a big challenge so and to write
the code that's going to do this for you
yourself which is take forever so this
is a huge offering from tensorflow so
thank you for that so anyways let's go
ahead and grab this stuff so so
I'm going to kind of assume that you do
have potential already and so again if
you don't I've got Stroh's on that
also make sure you basically have all of
this you can I mean you install it this
way but I would just install these
dependencies this way like pillow el XML
Jupiter MATLAB if you're on Windows
obviously without the pseudo if you do
need admin just open up CMD as an atom
so the only thing that might hang you up
on your installation on a boom tube is
if you're not on 1604 so they say 1604
and it's true but if you're on like 1404
for example like if you're using paper
space the people learning in a box
that's on a boom tube 1404 the only
thing that will hang what there is
basically you're put above compile
compiler and I will cover what you'll
need to do to fix that
so anyways make sure you have all these
including Jupiter pip install Jupiter
and then once you have those I think
I'll take it from here so so first thing
we want to do is is get the models
directory I'm going to just clone as a
zip if you're on a boom tube just get
clone github.com slash central as those
models don't get super simple while we
wait on that download I'm going to come
over here it's just github.com slash
google slash protobufs slash releases
and these are all the releases for the
protobuf compiler I'm going to because
I'm on Windows grab this one
so 4.32 save and if you need it on Mac
for whatever reason you could download
that here if you need it on a bin so you
can download that here in the process
will pretty much be the same at least on
a on on a boon to you would just extract
that zip folder just do sudo dot slash
configure so to make or sudo make check
and then sooner sudo make install on
Windows if you consider you don't really
have to do any of that to standalone so
anyway I'm going to move this over here
so let's go ahead and extract here the
models and then while that's running
whoops OH
move it and see well that's running I'm
also going to extract here Pro TOC which
is just going to slap it into bin here
now I'm going to leave it there just
because for this tutorial i would
suggest you probably take it and put it
in like your c program files or
something more useful than in downloads
at least if you're like me I clear out
downloads relatively frequently and so
eventually I would just delete this by
accident but I'm going to leave it here
and then we just specify the full path
so pro TOC is right and bin so yeah so
moving over here once you have those two
things we're going to come back over
here and pop into object detection so
the next steps are to setup that you
know point that compiler basically so
let me just come back over here
installation so it wants you to do the
protobuf compilation so from within that
models directory I want you to run this
now again if you're on a bin too and you
run this and I figured the area's but if
you get an error you probably outdated
Pro TOC you can check it by doing just
just in the command line your terminal
pro talk - - version if it's like 2.4 or
something that's the outdated version I
believe the most recent is 3.4 yeah so
if it's not 3.4 and you get in there go
ahead and update it that's probably your
problem so anyway so we need to do this
step as well on Windows so I'm going to
pop this over here inside models master
I'm going to go and rename this is just
a models that's what it is and inside
just straight up models you want to run
the following command so let's just go
ahead and copy that come over here CMD
right click now Pro talk isn't going to
you're going to get this pro tox now to
recognize blah blah so a lot of people
ask me about like this is like something
to me like I'm getting this unrecognized
command well it is not in your path we
could add it to our path if we wanted or
I'm just gonna specify the full path to
pro talk where did we go there we are
I hope it's big enough for you guys to
see
I think it is anyway
C colon slash users Saturday I think it
goes users H and it was in downloads
downloads slash bin slash proton I think
that's right oh it was right there I'm
blind
anyway yeah so we run that no errors
great we're good to go then if you're on
a boot - or probably Mac as well you're
going to want to export here to be
honest I don't even know what that lines
doing someone comment below and tell me
what the hell that line does I'm going
to wager that's not necessary on Windows
and then finally you could test the
installation but we're going to we're
just going to we're going to run the via
the Jupiter notebook so now we want to
do it let's go ahead and change
directory into object detection and now
I'm going to do Jupiter notebook and
that'll pop up the Jupiter notebook for
us come down where's I paint there we go
i pine notebook and this is just a very
quick demo basically what it's going to
do is it's going to download in fact
let's just run all and I'll kind of
explain what it's going to do so run all
what's going to do is it downloads a
pre-trained model for you and the
pre-trained model is this one here which
is coca which is stands for comp common
objects in context Barbic alright
I think it's 300 objects but I'm not
positive let's just a bunch of common
objects in context so anyway it's going
to download that it's a pre trained
model now later you could train it on
your own you can basically train your
own model if you wanted or you could
also train like you can continue to
train they're already pre trained models
so depending on what your goals are one
might be easier than the other
especially if you're like trying to
detect similar like things it's probably
it's pretty much always better to go off
a pre-arranged model so it's done
so this just runs a couple quick
examples that
on loads of images you got a dog and a
dog and then you've got that image that
was on there on their homepage basically
so running this whole ipython notebook
takes a little bit of time because
you're kind of setting everything up but
the actual detection process like this
here like this loop basically like once
you go into the session image can be
anything
this is iterating through just images in
the test paths which just downloaded two
images for you but this here this
process this loop is from what I've
found to be somewhere between like maybe
15 and 20 ish frames a second so you can
stream really well so anyway in the in
the next tutorial I'm going to show you
guys basically how we can take this you
know super simple demo basically and
begin to modify this loop here to do
what we want on our own kind of images
or video from either webcam or I'm going
to be using just video from like Grand
Theft Auto but you can use anything one
it's already a pretty good object
detector but if you want to detect
custom objects you'd want to train to
run so I'd also like to cover doing that
as well so anyways that's all for now if
you have questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise I will see you in another
video